it's the fourth night of Hanukkah and in
honor of the holiday guess who's here
once again this year Rabbi Levi harling
with Shabbat of Southern Nevada talk
about the meaning of Hanukkah and of
course we also have uh latkes and jelly
donuts as well we've got it all here
Rabbi it's good to see you once again
this year thank you for having us always
a pleasure to be on the show and happy
Hanukkah and to you as well so let's
talk about uh the story of Hanukkah sure
so story took place a little bit over 2
000 years ago Jews were under Greek
Syrian Rule and they came up with some
harsh decrees for bidding us from
keeping our religion practicing our
traditions two miracles of the Hanukkah
story Miracle number one the Jews formed
a small army called the makamis although
they were small in number they were
victorious in battle over the mighty
Greek Syrian Army Miracle number two
they come back to the temple clean it up
because it was desecrated destroyed by
the Greek syrians they wanted to light
the menorah they searched for some pure
olive oil now the one little drug which
is only enough to last for one day but I
believe in God as you know they let the
menorah had a lasted for eight nights
and eight days therefore you celebrate
Hanukkah for eight nights and eight days
and a lot of the traditional food
focuses around the oil because of the
miracle of the oil speaking of which
let's talk about some of the the
traditions of of Hanukkah that you've
brought with you we've got the menorah
in front of us of course and then on the
table here we've got uh the latkes which
are crucial to any solid celebration
exactly so potato Latka is deep frying
in oil jelly donuts custard donuts
chocolate vanilla whatever you want deep
fried oil again to celebrate the miracle
of the oil it's really a time to gather
through family
spend some time to recognize and
understand it was the victory of good
over evil and we can all be like the
menorah be a beacon of light out into
the world we have the menorah kits for
those that don't have a menorah candles
inside there we've got the chocolate
coins Chronicles also about education so
we give gifts to the children we have
the dreidels and the dreidels of course
which are you know part of the part and
parcel of Hanukkah let me see are you
familiar with the story adrenal story
let's hear it again real quickly so
dreidel has four four Hebrew letters
during the time of the decree the
children were not able to study the
Bible couldn't study the total but they
would go out into the caves and seek
release study when the Greek syrians
would approach they would hide their
Scrolls and say oh no we're just we're
just playing a game of drill as a
cover-up for their study so we play a
dreidel it's a competitive game play
with your family play with adults like
to play with real guilt real money
children play with the chocolate coins I
love that finally before we go here with
some of the celebrations happening
around there's so many of them of course
uh what's going on for the rest of
Hanukkah we got so we got me my dancing
dreidels we'll see a little bit soon all
over Vegas today we'll be at Henderson
hospital we'll be at the Clark County
Commissioner's Office later this evening
silver Knights tomorrow okay there's a
menorah parade with car top Menorah down
the strip Saturday night there's a
concert on Sunday in The Plaza Hotel all
over Vegas we're here to celebrate bring
the Hanukkah message out to the public
and coming up later here